So up to this point, we've created
our code almost purely from scratch,
using a few internal libraries
like HTTP Base Server and
external libraries like SQL Alchemy.
Creating a website from scratch really
shows that you have a good grasp of
underlying programming concepts and
are able to utilize the power of Python.
But as we make our website more and
more complex, the code becomes
repetitive and difficult to maintain.
Frameworks are collections of code that
simplify the web development process.
They take care of repetitive tasks and
allow us to focus on the more
unique features of our project.
At the moment, some of
the most popular frameworks out there
are RubyonRails.net and Django.
But if we take a look at this Wikipedia
article, we see that there are hundreds
of frameworks developers have created to
code web applications more efficiently.
Frameworks may rise and
fall in popularity but
the same underlying concepts for
developing web pages applies for
all of these technologies.
Think of a framework as
a box of prepared cake mix.
We could make a cake using all
of these items from scratch and
would probably have a better
understanding of how to make cakes.
But if we have several cakes to
make in a short period of time,
finding a good cake mix simplifies
the preparation process and
helps us focus on other things.
Like frosting.
In lesson two you built a website with
the raw ingredients of web development.
Now it's time to see how we
can use frameworks to improve
our development process.